[Música]
bienvenidos a este espacio de france 24
dedicado al medio ambiente soy maría
clara calle por marina colorado hoy
hablaremos de un nuevo intento por
proteger a las ballenas
el programa frenos de sí de la
organización mundial de sostenibilidad
lanzó la certificación whale safe o
ballenas seguras para intentar reducir
la cantidad de estos cetáceos que mueren
por choques con barcos aunque la
atención suele concentrarse en la casa
realmente los choques son una de las
mayores causas de muerte desde el año
2000 han aumentado las ballenas muertas
por choques con navíos y en 2020 cerca
de 20.000 de estos animales murieron por
ese motivo mientras que ese mismo año se
casaron aproximadamente 1.000 ballenas
ahora hay más muertes porque el comercio
marítimo ha aumentado drásticamente en
todo el mundo se pasó de 2.605 millones
de toneladas de carga transportadas por
el mar en 1970 a 11.000 76 millones de
toneladas en 2019
para proteger a las ballenas el programa
frenos de sí creó el sello well safe y
paolo bright el fundador del proyecto
nos explicó cuáles son los tres
propósitos primero de poner a bordo un
sistema de observación continua activo
durante la noche también normalmente
utilizando tele cámaras e infrarrojos
evidenciar la presencia eventual de
ballenas en frente
al buque y segundo punto de tener
prontos procedimiento para reaccionar y
evitar
el impacto con los mamíferos con los
mamíferos marinos y tercero punto es de
compartir toda esta información de
observación a través de una plataforma
online
-sí de producir más datos científicos
relevantes sobre los estado de las
poblaciones y también avisar los buques
que se encuentran atrás estas medidas
también buscan un mayor movimiento de
las ballenas pues muchas tienen
problemas para llegar a los sitios donde
se alimentan o donde se aparean como lo
mostró esta visualización de una ballena
azul en la patagonia del norte de chile
realizado por científicos y difundida
por el medio mongabay paolo asegura que
ya hay varias transportadoras
interesadas en el wales
si no siempre soy muy interesada a
utilizar el sello web safe y ya tenemos
cuatro empresas en el proyecto dos
empresas de bélgica y holanda aquí se
ocupan de transporte marítimo y dos
empresas de italia y reino unido- que se
ocupen de líneas pequeñas líneas de
crucero y dos más están convirtiéndose a
las nuestras auditorías para verificar
la cumplimiento con los requisitos en
los eeuu y en el reino unido y esperamos
realmente que las empresas en américa
latina' entiendan la importancia de esta
iniciativa y también también se unan al
proyecto pero vayan a seguras no es el
único programa de protección que han
lanzado últimamente en centroamérica
específicamente en belice
varias organizaciones ambientales se
unieron con el gobierno nacional para
adquirir y proteger 236 mil hectáreas
que hacen parte de la selva maya
de los sistemas ecológicos más
importantes del mundo y el bosque
tropical más grande que queda en la
región con cerca de 40 millones de
hectáreas la nueva área us está junto a
la reserva río bravo y juntas equivalen
a casi el 10% del territorio de belice
además este es un corredor vital para
que los monos aulladores negros los
tucanes el jaguar y todas las especies
características de la zona transiten
desde méxico y guatemala que son los
otros países que comparten la selva maya
uno de los socios del proyecto the
nation conservas y explica que la nueva
reserva permite proteger a la zona de la
deforestación y del cambio de uso de la
tierra hacia la agricultura que han
golpeado el área ambiental con todo esto
belice se sigue consolidando como uno de
los que más tierras y océanos conserva
pues casi el 40 por ciento de su masa
terrestre cuenta con algún nivel de
protección pero el país centroamericano
no es el único que se ha dedicado a
proteger las áreas de hecho américa
latina y el caribe es la región más
protegida del mundo según el más
reciente informe de cinco organizaciones
incluidas wwf la comisión mundial de la
uv y cn y el centro mundial para el
seguimiento de la conservación del abono
según el reporte un 24 por ciento de la
superficie terrestre latinoamericana y
un 19% de la marina tienen algún grado
de protección esto supera por mucho la
meta 11 de haití del convenio sobre la
diversidad biológica que plantea una
protección de al menos el 17 por ciento
en las áreas terrestres
y el 10% de las marinas sin embargo esta
protección no es representativa pues
sólo la mitad de los biomas superan la
meta y existen otros retos como lo
aseguró carlos mauricio herrera
especialista en áreas protegidas y
estrategias de conservación de wwf
colombia como nos lo explicó
inicialmente hay que hablar del tema de
la equidad es adecuada distribución
entre los costos y los beneficios de la
existencia de las áreas protegidas y
principalmente con las comunidades con
las familias que tienen una relación
mucho más cercana adicionalmente tenemos
un reto muy grande en términos de
planificación incluyendo los elementos
de cambio global principalmente estamos
hablando de cambio climático especies
invasoras uso con bajos niveles de
sostenibilidad en los territorios
asimismo hay un reto muy grande y es el
de la incorporación de las áreas
protegidas su visión y su trabajo en
contextos territoriales y de paisaje más
allá de los propios polígonos de las
áreas
finalmente mencionaría un tema de
sostenibilidad económica financiera las
áreas protegidas en nuestra región
siguen teniendo una gran falta de
recursos es todo por esta semana sigan
con más medioambiente en france 24 punto
com
[Música]